hallo herzlich willkommen in Sally Welt
heute gibt's mal wieder ein richtig
tolles Grundrezept wir werden nämlich
gemeinsam Windbeutel
[Musik]
machen Windbeutel bestehen aus einem
ganz klassischen Brandteig Brandteig
nennt sich so nicht weil er verbrannt
ist sondern weil er abgebrannt wird im
Top aus brantei könnt ihr erclairs
machen ihr könnt churos theoretisch auch
machen ihr könnt Windbeutel machen ihr
könnt so viele tolle Dinge machen und
das Besondere an Brandteig ist dass er
im Topf erstmal zubereitet wird dann
kommt er in den Ofen egal ob als kleine
Windbeutel oder als clclair und das
ganze pufft dann so richtig auf im Ofen
und da ist wirklich wichtig dass man die
Schritte hier so beachtet aber ihr
braucht keine Angst haben vor Brandteig
Brandteig ist wirklich gar nicht so
schwer und ich habe den als Kind schon
zubereitet weil meine Schwester immer
schon Windbeutel gemacht hat richtig
lecker mit Sahne gefüllt Windbeutel
Schwäne zubereitet hat deswegen ich ich
bin halt schon mit Brandteig
aufgewachsen und ihr bekommt heute das
Grundrezept dafür ihr verwendet dafür 60
g Butter 250 g Wasser etwas Salz 200 g
Mehl und dann brauchen wir etwa vier bis
fün Eier ihr seht auch schon die Eier
sind nicht aufgeschlagen denn es kann
einfach sein dass man ein Ei mehr oder
weniger braucht je nachdem wie groß sie
sind eins der wenigen Videos in denen
ihr mich gleich sehen werdet wie ich ein
Ei aufschlage denn normalerweise mache
ich das nicht so gerne ich habe so
bisschen so eine eierfobie und ich mag
die einfach nicht anfassen ich muss mir
dann sofort Hände waschen egal mache ich
gleich ich zeige euch jetzt die
klassische Zubereitung im Topf ich zeige
euch aber auch gleich wie Ihr diesen
Brandteig auch ganz einfach in eurer
Kenwood COOKING CHEF zubereiten könnt
ist nämlich noch einfacher als im Topf
ihr gebt jetzt Wasser Salz und Butter in
einen großen Topf dann kocht ihr das
ganze auf und am besten nehmt ihr dafür
diesen
backlöffel wer diesen backlöffel hat der
hat meinen Adventskalender letztes
[Musik]
Jahr
und sobald das butterwasser kocht gebt
ihr einfach das Mehl in einem Schwung
dazu es entsteht gleich ein richtig
dicker Klos aber ihr müsst jetzt einfach
ganz fleißig
rühren einfach rühren rühren
rühren schön dass das Mehl komplett
ummantelt ist mit
Wasser und jetzt immer weiter
rühren ich sag's euch da macht sich mein
Oberkörpertraining bezahlt früher habe
ich nicht so lange durchgehalten es ist
schon bisschen anstrengend aber es ist
okay ihr rötet so lange bis der Teig so
aussieht ein richtig schöner
geschmeidiger Teig am Topfboden bildet
sich so ein weißer
Belag das nennt sich jetzt
abbrennen jetzt ist er
fertig ich mach den Herd aus und hol
direkt eine große
röhrschüssel nehmen wir jetzt mal die
hier füll den Teig da
rein
so guck mal wenn man so drückt dann ist
herzle und jetzt fragen mich immer viele
wie bekomme ich diesen Topf wieder
sauber denn hier unten ist ja quasi der
abgebrannte Teig ihr l den Topf jetzt
einfach abkühlen und ich verspreche euch
wenn ihr den gut abgebrannt habt löst
sich das später wie so eine kleine
Teigschicht die könnt ihr sogar Essen
ihr könnt diesen Teig da unten essen wie
so ein kleines dünnes Knusperbrot ihr
lasst einfach abkühlen und dann muss man
da nichts schrubben nichts wegmachen und
dann könnt ihr den Topf ganz normal
reinigen jetzt habe ich hier den heißen
Teig ich streich den immer ganz gern am
Rand so ein bisschen hoch dass es so
ganz leicht
abkühlt und jetzt ist gleich wichtig
dass wir die Eier einzeln dazu geben und
entweder rührt ihr jetzt mit dem
Kochlöffel weiter mit diesem
backlöffel ist aber sehr anstrengend
oder nimmt handröhgerät mit Knethaken
das geht nämlich auch
wunderbar also ich schlage jetzt mal das
erste Ei hier rein und es tut mir jetzt
schon leid ich muss jetzt noch jedem Ei
die Händer waschen ich kann das nicht
[Musik]
anders ich mag halt keine Eier jetzt
nehmt euer handrückgerät dann kommt
immer ein Ei dazu und ich weiß am Anfang
sieht's aus als würde es sich nicht
verbinden aber bleibt dran bleibt stark
es wird ein schöner geschmeidiger Teig
und nach dem ersten Ei kommt das nächste
dazu und ich gebe nur so viel Eier dazu
bis ein schöner geschmeidiger glänzender
Teig entsteht aber ich zeig euch das
[Musik]
jetzt sieht aus als wä es falsch aber es
ist richtig einfach schön weiterrühren
weiterrühren bis es geschmeidig
ist am besten eine
Antirutschmatte so bleibt GLE die
Schlüssel besser guck Multitasking qu
ich bin ob ich mit einer Hand das Ei
aufgeschlagen
[Musik]
Kriege und wie wascht du jetzt deine
Hand die Hand wasche ich jetzt gleich
aber ich fasse einfach nichts anderes
mehr
an jetzt ist geschmeidig jetzt kommt es
hier rein und das nächste Ei
dran ich hoffe das war jetzt nicht so
ein Vorführeffekt wow
was ist da los ist hier wieder ein Brei
entstanden jetzt kommt wieder das
nächste dazu und es kann Hal sein dass
ihr drei Eier braucht kann aber auch
sein dass ihr fünf oder sechs braucht es
kommt einfach auf die eiergröße an und
wenn ihr jetzt zu viele Eier auf einmal
dazu gebt dann muss ich sagen kann es
passieren dass euer Teig nie geschmeidig
wird deswegen ein Ei nach dem
anderen
anstrengend deswegen zeig ich euch
gleich Version noch mit der
kennenw und der Teig war jetzt auch noch
sehr warm also ihr müsst nicht warten
bis der komplett kalt ist ihr nehmt den
warmen Teig jetzt nicht brennend heiß
aber so z D vi Minuten ist er abgekühlt
und dann macht ihr den
[Musik]
Teig
ich habe jetzt hier fünf Eier drin so
sieht der Teig momentan aus er ist zwar
schon geschmeidig aber wenn ich hier
durchziehe dann sind es noch keine
schönen glänzenden Spitzen das heißt
jetzt muss noch ein Ei
dazu sieht man hier der ist eher noch so
bisschen so brüchig keine schönen
glänzenden
Spitzen es kann aber jetzt auch sein
dass ein ganzes Ei zu viel wird deswegen
machen wir jetzt die Technik verquen wir
jetzt mal das Ei und geben erstmal ein
halbes Ei
dazu und dann kann es auch nicht
passieren dass ihr eins zu viel habt
also seid da einfach bisschen vorsichtig
und wie gesagt glänzende Spitzen
glänzender schöner
Teig wenn ihr den Brandteig jetzt in
eurer Kenwood COOKING CHEF zubereiten
wollt gebt ihr auch Wasser Butter und
Salz hier in die rührschlüssel ich
benutze jetzt einfach den Rühraufsatz
mit dem Silikon also hier diesen
flachhörer mit der silikonenseite denn
dann wird wirklich alles vom Rand auch
mit weggenommen also erstmal hier die
Zutaten
[Musik]
rein
180 brauchen wir jetzt hier nicht denn
ich will den Teig jetzt nicht frtieren
aber ich würde jetzt schon so auf 135
gehen und jetzt kommt das Mehl dazu und
ich kann anfangen zu rühren und dann
auch warten bis sich am Boden so ein
weißer Belag bildet und diesmal muss ich
nicht per Hand rühren sondern die
Maschine erledigt
[Musik]
alles
jetzt Füle ich den Teig direkt in die
kalte Schüssel ein und dann kann ich
schön die Eier einzeln dazu geben auch
hier sieht man ganz toll der weiße
abgebrannte
Boden bisschen Kräfte schonener ach so
jetzt hier die Temperatur natürlich
ausmachen
[Musik]
perfekt ihr könnt jetzt für die
Windbeutel entweder einen Esslöffel oder
eisporttion nehmen und dann einfach Teig
Häppchen auf euer Backblech setzen oder
ihr spritzt die gerne auf so mache ich
das jetzt und weil es ein richtig fester
Teig ist nehmt ihr am besten zwei
Spritzbeutel übereinander die sind zwar
echt richtig stabil und ihr könnt die
auch immer wieder verwenden aber da muss
man schon bisschen Kraft aufwenden
deswegen nehme ich ganz gerne immer zwei
da kann ich sicher gehen dass da die
Spritzbeutel eben auch ganz ganz stabil
sind und nicht aufreißen also einfach
ineinander stecken ich mache jetzt auch
noch ein Adapter dran damit ich mich
sicherer und besser fühle vor allem
könnt ihr mit so einem Adapter dann auch
immer die Spritztülle vorne
austauschen ich nehme jetzt hier so eine
ganz fein gezackte Sterntülle ihr könnt
aber auch eine lochttülle oder eine
normale Sterntülle nehmen ganz wie ihr
möchtet dann da
drauf und schon ist er
einsatzbereit dann
reinfüllen
ich habe jetzt hier natürlich die
doppelte Portion weil ich ja die
Teigportion in der kwood noch gemacht
habe das heißt wenn ihr das einfache
Rezept macht habt ihr etwa die Hälfte
davon
so Spritzbeutel nicht zu voll
machen dann habe ich jetzt hier meine
Backfolie gut
zudrehen und wenn ihr mit Spritzbeutel
arbeitet ich bin Rechtshänderin das
heißt bei mir führt die rechte Hand und
drückt hier hinten und die linke Hand
die führt eigentlich nur unten und ihr
drückt immer hier oben wenn ihr hier
unten drückt kann es passieren dass der
Teig rausschäßt also so generell beim
Spritzbeutel und jetzt einfach kleine
Häufchen machen denn sie werden im Ofen
sowieso groß wenn ihr Windbeutel macht
krokomusch kleine wie heißen diese
kleinen nicht Windbeutel sondern wie
heißen die auf
türkisch das französische Wort diese
Mini Windbeutel es liegt mir auf der
Zunge
erklär sind die langen und die
kleinen Prof R
profeterol also das wärden jetzt eher so
profiterol wenn ihr Windbeutel macht ich
zeige euch noch ein ble ich zeige euch
jetzt ein Blech profeterol und ein ein
Blech
windwutelchen schön mit Abstand denn die
gehen noch gut auf denn durch das
Abbrennen im Teig bildet sich sozusagen
so eine Art schutzkruste und die
Feuchtigkeit im Teig die will er dann
nach außen dringen beim backen und die
Teighülle hält es aber auf und deswegen
werden die so schön groß im Ofen dann
bleibt die Feuchtigkeit drinnen und dann
macht so gehen die richtig gut
auf wie
[Musik]
macht um den Effekt zu verstärken jetzt
am besten noch bisschen mit Wasser
beträufeln dann habt ihr noch bisschen
mehr Wasserdampf im Ofen wer eine
wasserdampffunktion hat kann die auch
gerne im Ofen benutzen ist hier herzlich
willkommen und dann ist das wichtigste
ihr habt jetzt bis hierher geschafft
dann dürft ihr beim Backen wirklich
nicht ungeduldig sein ihr packt sie in
den Backofen in vorgeheizten bei 200°
oberunterhitze und dann dürft ihr diese
Backofentür nicht öffnen nicht öffnen 25
Minuten lang und dann wenn sie schön
braun goldbraun sind macht ihr sie auf
aber wenn ihr sie zu früh öffnet fallen
sie zusammen und dann kriegt sie nicht
mehr gerettet deswegen hier jetzt schön
geduldig sein das sind schöne profeterol
jetzt machen wir noch paar
windnchbeutelchen falls Ihr hier noch
mal Teig auffüllt könnt ihr eine
Teigkarte nehmen und den Teig quasi nach
vorne schieben damit die Luft entweicht
und dann hat das echt ein bisschen
einfacher beim aufspritzen und das gilt
übrigens auch für Creme also wenn ihr so
Sahnecreme oder irgendwas drin habt noch
mal was auffüllt dann ist hier immer so
ein bisschen Luft dazwischen und die
kriegt ihr dann so raus und alle Reste
aus dem Spritzbeutel werden wirklich
komplett braucht Windbeutel machen wir
jetzt bisschen
[Musik]
größer
aus diesem Brandteig könnt ihr z.B auch
wunderbar ercllärs aufspritzen dafür
nehmt ihr auch eine Lochtülle oder eine
Tülle eurer Wahl und spritzt dann lange
Stränge
[Musik]
zu
hier habe ich jetzt alles gebacken ich
habe jetzt hier einmal die Windbeutel
ich habe die profiterol und ich habe die
eclers alles schon abgekühlt aber noch
nicht gefüllt und sowas könnt ihr auch
wirklich wunderbar einfrieren das heißt
wenn ihr euch mal hinsetzt und sagt
heute backe ich ganz viel könnt ihr
sowas immer wunderbar einfrieren und
habt dann immer frische Windbeutel
frische eairs oder frische profitarol
die ihr dann nach Belieben füllen könnt
ihr könnt natürlich auch aber hergehen
und später die gefüllten profiterol z.B
einfrieren dann schmecken sie genauso
wie die die man kaufen kann die gibt's
ja aus dem Tiefkühlfach und ich weiß
ganz viele auch aus meinem Team die
lieben diese und an sich sind die jetzt
hier außen immer schön gross und innen
weich und ihr könnt die weil sie ja
quasi neutral schmecken herzhaft und süß
füllen also ihr könnt jetzt hergehen und
Sahne oder Nougatcreme oder Früchte mit
reingeben ihr könnt aber auch sagen ich
ma eine lachscreme eine Frischkäsecreme
und könnt das Ganze eben auch herzhaft
gestalten ich zeige euch jetzt mal
einmal die Konsistenz
also bei den Windbeuteln ne erstmal bei
so ein erclair ich schneide das jetzt
hier einmal aus der Hand aber ihr macht
es bitte
nicht und dann sieht man richtig schön
diese luftige Konsistenz und ihr könnt
die aufschneiden und füllen oder auch
eine fülltülle nehmen und dann eben
einfach füllen das geht beides und ich
habe auch schon verschiedene Rezepte auf
dem Kanal und bei den Windbeuteln
genauso die könnt ihr auch hernehmen und
einmal
aufschneiden meine Schwester hat früher
auch immer Schwäne gemacht aus
Windbeutel kann ich euch auch mal zeigen
aber ich ma dann das Video wi mit meiner
Schwester machen hier dann habt ihr so
eine richtig schöne luftige Konsistenz
guckt mal und da passt eben richtig viel
Füllung rein das ist perfekt ich werde
jetzt hier einfach noch zwei drei
verschiedene Versionen machen und zwar
gibt's gleich Eclairs mit lotuscreme es
gibt profeterol mit Früchten und es gibt
Windbeutel mit einer mondcreme und Lemon
Curt das lecker da gibt's dann auchch
einzelne Shorts dazu und die Rezepte
gibt's auch einzeln auf meinem Kanal
also los geht's mit den erlärs mache ich
jetzt aber so die werde ich nicht
aufschneiden die werde ich einfach mit
einer füllthülle
befüllen starten wir mal mit
den für die Eclairs nehme ich jetzt hier
ein bisschen lotuscreme und zwar die
cremige habe sie in der Mikrowelle
erwärmt und in einen Spritzbeutel rein
mit einer füllthülle und die werden
jetzt einfach von oben
reingefüllt von oben befüllt in beide
Richtungen um zu checken ob ihr genug
Creme drin habt oder wie viel da drin
ist könnt sie auch gerne auf eine Waage
stellen quasi vorher nachher oder
einfach nur nach
[Musik]
Gefühl
dann geht's jetzt weiter mit den
Windbeuteln und die schneide ich jetzt
auf und fülle sie dann mit der mondcreme
und Lemon Curt und falls ihr mal einen
Windbeutel hatt der so bisschen außer
Form geraten ist könnt ihr den
tatsächlich mit dem richtigen Schnitt
retten und zwar schneide ich dann
einfach so erstmal den
Boden nehm das Zwischenstück Weg der für
die schiee verantwortlich ist und dann
zack ist er wieder
perfekt und das hier könnt ihr dann
essen das ist dann zum
gleichlaschen ich liebe wie ein
[Musik]
Beutel
bei den profeterol mache ich jetzt so
ich fülle sie mit geschlagener Sahne da
ist Vanilleextrakt und bisschen
Puderzucker mit drin und dann habe ich
hier schon zaritter Schokolade
geschmolzen ein paar Früchte dazu
perfekt sind sie
perfekt und und dass wir noch ein paar
profiterol füllen und einfrieren damit
sie sind so wie die
gekauften mit geschlagener Sahne ihr
nehmt jetzt quasi mit einer
fülltülle jetzt habe ich schon wieder
keinen Adapter
dran denk dran ein Adapter zu nehmen
dann habt ein bisschen mehr Druck drauf
dann geht ihr da rein
zack schön
auffüllen da muss man jetzt so bisschen
mit Gefühl
arbeiten und dann wisst ihr
auch das man fühlt dann wenn es voll
[Musik]
ist hier habe ich jetzt also meine
fertigen Windbeutel die erclair und die
profiterol kurz überlegt wie sie heißen
ich vergesse jedes Mal profiterol
ich mer mir jetzt einfach okay ihr könnt
natürlich aus dem Brandteig auch churos
zubereiten ihr könnt so so spritzgebck
machen ihr könnt aus Brandteig auch was
Größeres Backen also Brandteig hat
wirklich ganz ganz viele Facetten und
wir können gerne noch viele viele
Rezepte damit machen schreibt einfach
gerne in die Kommentare jetzt hole ich
aber endlich mal wieder unseren besten
Verkoster den wir hier haben okay warte
wir haben mehrere beste aber es ist
einer der besten es ist einer der besten
den wir hier haben
Tim
hallo oh haben auch lange nicht gesehen
aber ich bin der beste Verkoster ja ja m
und es gab lange nichts Süßes hier bei
uns und jetzt gibt's
viel si sehr lecker aus ich habe
Brandteig gemacht und dann also das ist
mit
zitronem Lotus Schokolade Früchte du
musst dich nicht entscheiden du kannst
auch alles nehmen ich würde einmal alles
probieren ja ja einmal alles durch
einmal alles durch okay dann hau rein
ich habe schon ich habe ja die reels
dafür noch gemacht ich habe den den
Brandteig jetzt hier heute für euch
gemacht habe ich noch einzelne rezeptres
gemacht ich habe alles essen müssen ich
kann nicht mehr ich kann nicht mehr
probier aber überall eins wird schon ein
bisschen viel ja ist viel dann beiß
einfach rein oder sowas abschneiden ach
das geht auch das kannst auch so komm
hau rein das kriegen auch so nicht dann
nimmst dir einfach so eins Weg so
liliegt die heilwäre M ist egal GCK die
hängt sogar dran an der Schokolade
oh guck
SHF und da ist Sahne
[Musik]
drin kurz überlegt weiß rein oderut das
sich ich habe aber einmal hier ich kann
es euch zeigen ich hab nämlich gerade
fürs real einmal
angebissen ja so sieht es innen aus
schon gut aber die sind sehr lecker oder
ich ma direkt weiter ja mach direkt
weiter jetzt wird schon
viel deswegen meine Mama die mag
eigentlich Windbeutel nur mit
sahnefüllung da kann man ewig ewig essen
aber so mit Schokolade ist schon heftig
und mit Lotus dann noch mal heftiger ja
ja
so schön ord ordentlich
reinweißen fun fact erklär nennen sich
auch
Liebesknochen hat er jetzt einfach
ignoriert
und war ich fluffig lecker ich hab es
auch mit Lotus gefüllt ich lieb Lotus
sieht man das ja so zeig mal die
Kamera si
gut
ja ich sag doch er ist der
beste ich finde das und das geht ja noch
so zum Reinbeißen Windbeutel das wird
hart wer macht das jetzt du die hinter
der
Kamera ich habe ich habe vorhin auch
reingebissen es war schon
ja krass du ist sogar
auf ich dachte ich soll nur probieren
eins probieren ach so eins probieren den
Rest nimmst du dann ja okay okay h recht
Tim in 10 Jahren so 30 Kil
schwerer wie war wie er gingst dir 10
Jahre sellis Welt ich dachte deshalb ist
doch alles hier Rollstuhl barrierefrei
alles barrierefrei dass ich essen kann
noch hochrollen
so sieht das
aus aha
m sieht schon nicht schlecht aus wie
soll man den denn jetzt essen ich würde
sagen wir drücken den jetzt einfach
so und dann
probieren oh ich
habe
[Gelächter]
ich dachte mir gerade ich stell mich an
aber du stellst ja genauso an zum Glück
kann ich auch nicht
essen
mhm mhm
was war dein
Favorit mein Favorit ist
zitronemon ich finde der ist so richtig
frisch fruchtig so wer Schoko liebt auf
jeden Fall
und Lotus ich noch nehmen nimm dir noch
ein Liebesknochen du noch liebes Weg
viel hil
[Gelächter]
viel
also während der Tim sich hier noch
durchprobiert ich gleich meine Hände und
mein komplettes Gesicht waschen
muss könnt ihr gerne schon mal einen
Kommentar da lassen wie ihr das Video
fandet den Kanal abonnieren damit sie
nichts mehr verpassen die Glocke
aktivieren haben wir direkt alles mit
dabei und das Rezept gibt's wie immer
auf sellis-blog.de oder in meiner
kostenlosen App die können ihr gerne
runterladen probiert jetzt aus viel Spaß
lecker oder richtig gut und schreibt
gerne eure rezeptwünsche noch rein bis
[Musik]
с